yo you talked about a day where you were
at Gucci Mane's house the Migos were
there Thug was there Scooter was there
Gucci Mane I always say probably is the
greatest a r in hip-hop history but but
like what I what he don't get enough
credit for he sees it and he be right 89
of the time and he sees it before it
happens
to sign the artist right listen it's not
man RP the Dolph was over there too
listen man then goo walk was pulling up
on me at my mom wait Dolph was at the
house at the same time nah this is a
different room so Gucci trying to sign
me so now Thug already signed the Gucci
yeah he had the Migos too he had the
Migos
are y'all over there so you know trying
to real coin then so I'm styling them
out I'm styling them out so I come at
him out of town he's like man where you
at I'm like bro I'm at my mama house but
I'm really just like you know I might go
I might not come pick you up
I would like uh
[ __ ] my side I go outside man but my
girl would tell her to come on too wow
he come pick me up man come pick me up
in the red Bentley he was like yeah only
two people got these in the USA he
popping off in the car with him first
time at me though so Dolph and Gucci
pick you up from your mom's house yeah
man dog would go but he was living in
Atlantic Station
and I just remember saying Dolph on them
because I didn't know like at this time
I didn't I'm not dolphins not golfed off
yet right you know what I'm saying like
nobody I'm not I'm not even Rich Homie
Quan yet right you know what I'm saying
but dogs is like standing up sleep on
the elevator we both spent a night in
Goose living room you and dog crashing
on the couches in Gucci's living room
yeah but because we couldn't go home he
was like you know it's a friendly kid
now like you ain't going home so just
work Randy kid now but we haven't worked
yet so I know like yeah Brian what
remind you and my girls here too yeah
man so let me get this straight so Gucci
pulls up to your house in a red Bentley
with young Dolph yeah
friendly kidnaps you and your lady yeah
you guys end up at his house you end up
crashing there in the living room with
dolphins yeah
because Gucci is courting to you to sign
with with a brick squad no I wouldn't
even just yeah he wanted me to sign yeah
he wanted me to sign so you go over to
his house you guys end up recording
I don't even know man because he was
upstairs man [ __ ] down you know what I'm
saying because like the log like they
didn't have no door like
all right
man I'm trying to get some [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying but you know what I'm
saying it was a moment bro like you know
what I'm saying Wild